welcome everyone as you come and
i uh i'm excited to have to have uh the
february meet up this month
we're gonna get started some
announcements to get everything going
uh first up we always like to start the
meetup with
who's hiring obviously we can't exactly
do that right now because we're in this
virtual world
hopefully soon we'll get out of the
virtual world soon being relative
so if you have a job if you are looking
to hire someone
go to the ny hackgar slack and go to the
job postings channel
put your job in there hopefully you'll
get a bunch of people applying and
hopefully one day soon you could
get their applications in person i want
to thank eco health alliance for
sponsoring uh for providing the zoom
zoom session for us
and they would actually like to announce
that they have a job they're hiring for
us that'd be pretty cool
hi thanks jared um hi everyone my name
is emma mendelson i'm a research
scientist
at eco health alliance and we are hiring
right now for a data librarian
it's going to involve a lot of working
with teams across the organization to
help them figure out their data
management needs
and to provide some support with data
analysis visualization
also some engineering so it's a super
nice chance to work for
a really great organization um to help
us build new tools and systems and to
help us develop best practices for data
management
and we're looking for someone with
strong our skills data organization
skills and we're also especially
interested to hear from folks who have
knowledge of the scientific publication
process and familiarity with the
ecosystem around
scientific archiving and metadata so if
that's interesting to you the post is
online at our website
and also please feel free to reach out
to me emma mendelson or noah ross who's
the supervisor for this position
we're both on the new york r slack
channel thanks jared
great thank you and since i'm on camera
i am hiring i am hiring an account
executive
so you want to join my company to help
bring r and python and data science
machine learning in general to companies
we are looking for someone with
technical experience to help along the
sales process
and you not only get a just help grow
the company but help with the conference
and make people really enjoy these open
statistical tools
so if you're looking to maybe do some
sales you know someone who likes sales
send them toward me or send yourself
so the pizza this month is coming from a
local place called
marcos see we have good cheese lock
cheeses and sliding
you see based on the uniform color it
was made in a gas oven
and i'm looking forward to trying that
so i hope everybody else hope you got
pizza from somewhere good somewhere
local near you
uh let us know let us know in the in the
chat or in slack where you got your
pizza from
hopefully we could all live vicariously
through each other all these different
great pizza places
hope you guys are enjoying it um
so again we're all use this by now but i
know not everyone here has been here
before
or in virtual land so if you want to
chat about what's going on here
and check out this cool talk we have two
spots for you
you can go in the chat right here in
zoom or
you can go into the ny hack r slack
there is now a chat called
monthly meetup chat um it's the same one
we've been using for the past few
meetups we just give it one name instead
of keep changing it
so go to monthly meetup chat in slack
and ask questions there
what we're going to do is you folks will
ask questions there
i'll compile them all at the end and i
will ask them of andy at the end
this way we can get everyone's questions
in so again if you want to ask a
question you just want to
chat about your pizza or about how the
talk's going or about anything else
go to the monthly meetup chat for
those of you that are new to the slack
we have lots of channels in there
including our help python help
get help stats help all sorts of
different help channels
and an events channel if you want to
learn about events that are happening
and a job posting channel and many other
private channels and public channels
that i'm not even aware of
some other news we just last week posted
all the videos from the r government
conference they're all online freely
available to get
you go to rstats.ai and there's a video
button and they're all in there so again
i'll put that in the group chat actually
rstats.ai uh you click
on the videos and actually you'll see
six years worth of videos between the
new york and the washington and the
government conferences
so there's lots of videos up there
speaking of videos uh we posted the
january meetup video last week also
so if you want to find that video of
last month's talk
you can go to nyhackr.com and click on
the presentations link and you'll see
um last month's video the past eight
years worth of videos
there is a bug in the website discovered
that in the table showing the
information
you might need to resize it to get to
the videos so
we are redesigning that but all the code
is up on github for that website
so if you want to help redesign both the
website and the table display
we'll take a pull request because right
now we're working on it
but we're always open to people who
could do better designs because i
designed the first one
and i don't do design so be great if
someone else actually know what they're
doing made it look pretty
next month we have garrick adam bu and i
hope i'm pronouncing his name correctly
garrick if you're here i apologize if i
got your name mangled
he'll be speaking about sharing it i am
super excited for this talk sharingan as
a lot of you know is this
uh popular sideshow format in our he's
going to give a whole talk about
sharagan and sharon gunn extra and a
whole bunch of cool stuff
in april we have klaus wilkie talking
about
how to use r and rust together you might
notice today's talk has
a bit about rust in april we're going to
talk about how call rust functions from
r so we're super excited about that and
then in may we have james lamb
who's going to talk about light gbm for
those who don't know this is a
competitor to xgboost
and depending on the benchmarks it's
either faster or more accurate
so it's going to be really cool to see
that talk i'm super excited about them
they're recently getting themselves on
cran
as gpu support so that's going to be a
really cool new addition to the r
ecosystem
so with all that we have a talk today
about arrow
those of you know i've been uh trolling
neil richardson a little bit on
twitter about arrows he's given a bunch
of talks at our conference
about arrow um really super excited
about this
so everyone please give a warm virtual
welcome you won't hear us all clapping
i'll golf clap for you please welcome
andy to give a talk tonight thank you
very much andy
thank you happy to be here hopefully
everybody can see my screen
i'm sure somebody will tell me if not um
okay so hi i'm andy grove i'm here to
talk about rust apache aero and a
project called ballista
i've been working on for a while so
first just a
real quick introduction so i've been a
software engineer
forever started off with some really
obscure technology in the late 80s
uh moved to c plus for a while and then
i've been doing a lot of java and jvm
work for the past
20 years and more recently i got really
excited about rust
and at the same time i was working with
scada and spark which is a really cool
system
and this kind of got me thinking
well sparks really cool but what if we
had built spark in rust
and you know what would that look like
and this really started a journey
for me over the past few years where i
started to build
various pieces of data technology and
rust trying to work towards this goal
and along the way there's been a few
different projects that have been
created
uh starting with a sql parser library so
that's kind of a thing you need
um through this then i discovered apache
arrow which seems really cool
but it wasn't a rust implementation so i
was able to create the first the first
step was a
rust native implementation of arrow and
then
with those pieces in place i moved on to
another component called data fusion
which i heard there's a question there
and we're going to go into detail on
rust and data fusion and arrow in the
slides and then ultimately bathista is
the new project
and the thing i wanted to achieve at the
start which is building something like
apache spark in rust this is now
the piece that's provided by ballista
so
so i guess the first question is why
arrow so when i started on this journey
i actually started off with a very naive
way of building a query engine
which was actually row based so when the
queries are running they're processing
one row at a time
and it turns out that's really expensive
um so if you're looking at just a subset
of columns in a table
um there's a lot of overhead you're
loading all the data for each row into
memory you're skipping over the pieces
that you're not interested in
and so column known column of processing
is just
kind of the way people do it these days
and very quickly some people pointed me
to arrow
and error makes a lot of sense um many
data projects already have some degree
of support for arrow
although it's often for integration
right now because obviously these
projects
were built you know maybe before arrow
was popular
or mature um but arrow is really being
adopted as the d factor
standard for columnar data in memory and
for kind of ipc and integration
so it seems to make really good sense
for me to just choose arrow from the
start for building this new data
platform
and of course i'm not the only person to
think an arrow is a good idea
and i think we're going to be seeing a
lot of new projects over the next you
know two or three years
that's a kind of built from the ground
up to be arrow native
and i showed you slides afterwards of
course but here are just a few of the
projects
that have chosen to use arrows their
memory format
so the next question is i guess arrow's
cool but white rust
um as you saw from my background i've
been in you know
using java and jvm forever it'd be kind
of natural for me to use that
um java's you know java's really great
it's very productive this is really
mature ecosystem
there's so many people out there that
can build java components it has a lot
going for it
um but unfortunately it's not really
suitable for
big scale data processing in my opinion
because of
the garbage collection um so the thing
that drew me to rust is that it has the
similar performance to c plus plus but
it has
the um it has it has a unique approach
to memory management it has the
safety that you get with the garbage
collector but without the overhead
and i won't go into too much detail on
how that works but basically the rust
compiler
tracks the memory allocation in your
code so if you're trying to do
bad things in your codes your code won't
even compile so you don't have issues
like freeing memory and then using it
after it's freed
you don't have issues with multiple
threads writing to the
same piece of memory at the same time so
that's really cool you get the speed
you get the safety and more importantly
for big data
and data processing you get very
predictable and consistent performance
because there are no gc pauses and
you know if on the downside there is a
steep learning curve
especially for some of the more advanced
features and the language is still
maturing
okay so i'm going to take a bit of a
deeper dive into apache arrow
starting with the specification but then
going into kind of some rust
specific details
so the irs specification has kind of
grown over time it started out as a
specification for a memory format and
basically it's very efficient um
arrow arrow structures you know arrow
presumably are playing the word array
if you have fixed length data types like
integers or floats
then your values are stored in
contiguously in memory in a buffer
and when you have variable length data
your data is still in a contiguous
buffer but now you have another buffer
with the
offsets for where the different values
start and end
and having the contiguous memory makes
the format very
uh suitable for processing using
vectorized processing on modern hardware
so using simd features on gpu which is
simultaneous input multiple data
basically the cpu can process multiple
pieces of data with one instruction
and gpus especially i mean they're
designed for vectorized processing so
it's a very natural fit there too
so that's the kind of the memory format
there's also an ipc format
so when you want to share this memory
between two processes
that are in different languages you you
can share the memory form you can share
the memory directly because of the
specification
but you need to have some metadata
describing the layout
of the the data structures so the ipc
specification
provides a format for exchanging that
metadata
um but the data itself could be shared
in memory or if it does have to be
serialized over the wire
it's kind of a zero copy operation
because the memory format is also the
serialization format
you can just stream those bytes to
another process and it can then read
them
and then more recently um there's a new
flight
protocol in arrow so this is really
exciting for me because this takes arrow
and makes it suitable for distributed
processing
so flight is grpc based so protocol
buffers
and it defines an interface for
exchanging streams of
error data between processes
and also methods for exchanging queries
and exchanging metadata
um sarah has implementations in a ton of
languages i think it's like 12 or 13 at
this point
um the c plus plus in the java library
is the most mature
and some of the other libraries kind of
reuse that so the python and our
libraries for example dedicate to c plus
um so the libraries provide this memory
format but then we have computational
kernels
so you have these data structures in
memory and arrow formats
you want to perform operations on them
so maybe you want to add
two arrays of integers or perform some
aggregation
so some of these libraries including c
plus plus java and rust
have these computational kernels in the
libraries you to use
and then the next layer up uh some of
these libraries provide
query engines so i know the most about
the rust implementation into the data
fusion query engine
there's also a lot of work happening
right now in the c plus plus
implementation
so to dive into the rust implementation
in a little bit more detail
um i'm going to be showing some code
examples these are some of the key
data types and structures involved so
arrow has a type system
um so you have schemas which are made up
of fields fields have data types they
can be primitive or complex
uh for each type there are builders
provided for building arrays of that
type
and i mentioned these compute kernels so
the rust implementation has a bunch of
those so there's
you know math string functions filters
aggregation
and so on and if you're dealing with
tabular data which
most of us are there's a concept of a
record batch
so these are batches of columnar data
with a known schema
when we look at those in a moment and
then also in the rust library we have
some i o
so the ability to read and write csv
json parquet
to and from native arrow for memory
format
so here's a trivial example so this is
building
uh an arrow array of 32-bit
integers signed integers so we create a
builder
and then we can append values or append
null values
and when you append no you're not
actually well depending on the data type
in this case
there would be a memory used but if you
have variable length data
appending null means that you you're not
actually writing any data to the main
buffer
and your offset buffer would have two
consecutive values the same to indicate
that there's kind of a null value
so so it's very simple example and then
this is a trivial example of
using a compute kernel so here we're
starting out with two arrays we have an
array of integers
we have an array of booleans and here
we're using a
filter kernel to filter the array of
integers based on the
bit set provided by this boolean array
so
you know imagine how this is used in
something like data fusion if you're on
a query it has a where clause
um you would evaluate the filter
expression in the where clause to get
your array of booleans
and then pass that into a filter to
filter the
the arrays and the record batches that
you're processing
and the record batch structure is very
simple it can as a schema
and then a vector of um arrays so in the
rust implementation
we use downcasting so if you have an
array ref you need to know
the schema so you know what type you're
dealing with and then you can basically
cast the array to a specific type
and then access the those type safe
methods
so that's kind of a you know quick run
through arrow and the primitives
provided there
um so now i want to go into data fusion
which is kind of the next level up the
stack
so this is an in-memory query engine it
has a sql and data frame api
and um so we can query the the formats i
mentioned previously
so csv park a json it can also process
memory that's already sorry it can
process
data that's already in memory um which
is obviously incredibly efficient so
there's all kinds of cool integrations
you can do there
we're using the tokyo runtime for
multi-threaded support
so it's an async library which is
working out really well
so looking at the architectural data
fusion specifically it's
you know very similar to any other query
engine
the starting point is building up a
logical query plan
so you can do this through a data frame
api um
which i imagine many people here are
familiar with
and in data fusion if you use sql the
sql query planner
actually just delegates to the data
frame api so
regardless of which api you choose to
use you're going to end up with
basically the same query plan
um data fusion has some some basic query
optimizations
things like filter push down so let's
say you're joining two tables and you've
got some
predicates in your where clause it will
try and apply those filters
before you do the join to minimize the
data being joined um there's some other
optimizations
in there as well one of the really cool
things with data fusion
especially with the 3-0 release that
came out recently
is that there are a bunch of extension
points now
so it's very easy to take data fusion
and use it in another library or
framework like ballista and get all the
data fusion functionality for free but
then
extend it so in my case in ballista
i'm taking data fusion and extending it
for distributed
query execution
so these are the the operations we
currently support and data frame
it isn't as rich as um you know some
material products out there yet but it
has enough to support
quite a wide range of real world queries
so you can do
you know joins and aggregates and
sorting and so on
so here's a code example for using the
uh data frame api so it's very simple
you create a context
then you can call methods on the context
to
access the initial data so there's a
read barca method
um digivision also supports custom table
providers you can write your own table
providers to read from
which is great for integration and then
you call other methods
to basically build out your
your query plan so the effect here of
calling read parquet
and select columns and filter this isn't
actually processing any data
it's just building up a query plan and
in the last line here where we call
collect on the data frame
that's where the query actually the
logical plan gets you know translated to
a physical plan
and executed and that returns a future a
tokyo
a rust feature that you can you wait on
for the results
and here's a secret example so again you
start with the context
and so in sql you want to reference
tables
so you need to register your data source
as tables so that they can be referenced
from sql so here we're registering a
parquet
file uh we're giving the table name all
types underscore plane
and then we can pull a sql method on the
context
give it a sql string and we get back a
data frame
um the data frame you get so you can
register any data frame
as a table with the context as well so
you can kind of mix and match between
data frame and sql apis
and again this example is just calling
collect at the end um so collect brings
the results back into memory
um the other options are you could have
the results written out to
any of the supported formats with a
write method
okay so so far um so we've gone from the
compute kernels to an in-memory query
engine so that's great
but the thing i really wanted to do was
make this distributed
so that you can do spark like etl
processing or queries
so um so this is the eventual
architecture diagram
and i'll explain in a minute what
actually exists now and what doesn't
um but talking through this this is the
part where i am pretty excited about
arrow and the potential house building
at new systems
so the basic design of ballista is that
there is a cluster of distributed
processes
the main components are the scheduler
and the executor
they all have grpc interfaces um the
executive support the arrow flight
protocol for streaming data
so the basic flow would be from a client
in whatever language
you'd send a query plan serialized as
protocol buffers
over the flight protocol to the
scheduler the scheduler can then
um compile the physical query plan using
data fusion
it can then translate it into a
distributed query plan
with extensions to data fusion to do
that and then start
scheduling fragments of that query
across the executors
and as each executor executes a fragment
of this query
the results get streamed to disk in
arrow iepc format so again arrow is
helping out
and the executives can stream that data
between themselves
and when the query finishes the clients
the information that the client receives
back from the scheduler
isn't the actual result set it's a list
of locations full of results
which could be distributed across many
executives
so this is one of the really cool things
about the flight protocol the client can
now stream those results in parallel
from all of the executors
so you don't have this kind of
bottleneck of
um kind of forcing all the results back
through a single driver process
to get back to the client um
on the left-hand side obviously with
because this is very standard space
it'll be possible to build drivers in
you know any you know many different
languages
um on the right-hand side of the diagram
in the
cluster i've got some boxes there for
like
uh java python and gpu um so
one of the really cool things is this
scheduling ballista even though it's
implemented in rust
it doesn't care what language the query
gets executed in
so you can send out these query plan
fragments to any other process
so it'd be possible to execute parts of
it in java because maybe you have some
custom java code that you need to call
as part of a query or maybe you want to
go to the gpu
so nvidia has this really cool rapids
qdf library
which is a gpu data frame library so
that can
that can simply slot in as well so
that's the eventual architecture which
i'm excited to get to
what actually exists today is a little
bit smaller um
so ballista 0.4 was just released a few
days ago
and it's possible to execute distributed
queries
uh there's a rust client that supports
sql and data frame api
and there are some python bindings for
that rust client as well
um so that's basically what we have
today
um so to go into a bit more detail about
how this actually works i've kind of
mentioned some of this already
um and the design here is very much
inspired by apache spark particularly
the adaptive query execution feature
which i think is new in 3.0
so basically though so you have this
whole query plan for your
your query you need to run so there
could be multiple nested joins your data
could be partitioned differently
at different stages of the query so
ballista will break the query plan down
into query stages and
so what defines a query stage a query
stage is basically
a set of operators that have the same
partitioning
so those query stages can be executed in
parallel across the cluster
in a very scalable way and
the output of one query plan b is the
input for another query plan or maybe
the eventual results
so you end up with this dag of
query stages that have to be executed
and one of the really nice things about
this approach is that
once you've executed the child so let's
say we're doing a join
the join has two inputs left and right
once you've executed those
child query stages you actually have
like accurate statistics
so you know like how many bytes how many
rows how many batches
um maybe days from you know how fast
this is
and this allows you to apply
optimizations
dynamically as you're executing the
query um
so for example you know if if one side
of a joint is really small then maybe
you'll just do a hash join
um but if the if if both sides are
really large you
you're going to need a more scalable
join algorithm so you might need to do
like a sort of edge join for example and
as i mentioned earlier
all the so between these query stages
data needs to be kind of shuffled around
between the executors
and that's where the arrow ipc format
comes in
with the data being streamed either
between processors using flight
or if you know these executives they
could sometimes be co-located
so in that case there are optimizations
where you can stream directly from
the local local shuffle files
and this diagram shows the interaction
in a bit more detail the protocol level
so um from client to scheduler there's a
grpc interface which isn't really part
of the flight standard
um but there's this is how the plan or
sql statement gets submitted
and a result um gets returned with like
a query id
and then the client right now can pull
the scheduler to see
um you know if the query is complete and
the scheduler uses the flight protocol
to execute the partitions across the
executors
and then the client audio executives can
fetch those partitions
using the flight protocol
so i got the invite from jairus did his
talk just uh pretty recently
and this all kind of stemmed from
somebody posting ballista and hacker
news
and i wasn't really quite ready to like
go just public with it
um but it kind of acted as a forcing
function for me to get a release out
with help from a lot of other people
so the first the first really usable
release of the list was just a few days
ago
and it uses the latest and greatest
arrow data fusion code from github
directly
um it supports deployment as a
standalone cluster
it supports docker compose and
kubernetes and
yes it can actually execute distributed
queries now it supports
in theory exports all of the queries
that data fusion supports
and um it can run some real query so we
have some benchmarks that are very
loosely based on one of the industry
standard
benchmarks that people run with these
tools and i'll show you some
benchmark results soon but what we're
seeing right now at this very early
stage is that some of the queries are
twice as fast as spark
and others are considerably slower which
is to be expected because we haven't
implemented all of the optimizations
uh that we need to do especially around
join algorithms
and the current focus now is on um so
you know it basically works and then we
have to do the work of adding support
for different
operations expressions and implementing
these optimizations so that we can scale
really well
so here are my relatively fair
benchmarks and
the reason i say that i've been through
um but lister started a couple years ago
and it's really kind of a hacky
prototype and it's kind of evolved and
then it's becoming real
and throughout this time i've always
tried to run some benchmarks to kind of
compare to spark
and they've always been extremely unfair
because um
ballista couldn't do the things that
spark did it wasn't distributed until
recently
um so these are actually the first
benchmarks that have run where ballista
is an actual cluster
and spark is running as a cluster they
have the same number of nodes they're
running the same hardware and
running the exact same queries um so the
data set is relatively small it's 100
gigabytes
and that's really the reason that this
is still unfair spark is
designed and optimized for big data and
100 gigs isn't really
very big data so um but still it gives a
good indication so currently
even with this very early release
without the optimizations
we're kind of seeing we're kind of on
par with spark a bit faster here a bit
slower there but it's very promising
um for the future once we start to to
optimize this
so in terms of the road map and take all
of this with a
you know pinch of salt this is we're
very early on but in my mind this is the
way i'm kind of looking at progress from
today forward
so we have a 0.4 release that works and
there's a whole bunch of kind of
incremental improvement work we need to
do there
especially around things especially with
things like deployment
and documentation and just some there's
some simple optimizations we need to
make
and then i think what's really going to
be exciting is that
kind of the next major release the 0.5
release that's where we get to the point
that it is really a compelling
alternative to spark for
queries against larger data so in the
terabyte scale
um so there's a few optimizations we
need to get in to enable that
and this will be the release that uses a
published version of apache arrow rather
than
using the latest from github um i think
adbc driver is really important
there is a processor that works at one
point and currently is broken
but with a jdbc driver you can start
using business intelligence tools
things like clio cortablo to actually
run queries against the data
and um and the thing i'm really excited
about is gpu support
so i mentioned rapids qdf they have a
gpu dataframe library
you give it a query plan it executes it
blister has a query plan
so the basic process is to have an
executive running that can take the
blister query plan
translate it to a qdf query plan and
execute it
qdf conveniently is built based on arrow
so it's pretty much the same date the
memory format
so it should be incredibly efficient to
move data back and forth
and then of course 1.0 everything else
and
so i guess we'll see how it goes there's
a community building around the project
we've had contributions from around 30
people so far
i think there are uh six or seven people
that are pretty active right now
so there's all these features we need to
build it's hard to predict the timeline
because everybody's working on it
as a kind of volunteer effort so i work
on it in my spare time
um but i'm excited that we have we've
kind of reached a critical mass now we
have the
the basic stable product and then
there's some momentum
so i'm yeah i'm gonna be excited to see
what happens over the remainder of 2021.
so i think that's kind of um i've maybe
blasted through that a little quickly
that's basically the presentation um and
there's a shameless plug for my book so
i wrote a book about query engines a
while back
it's just an introductory guide but it
walks through
kind of all the steps of building a
query engine from passing sql
to how you know what query plans look
like how optimizations work
and so on and i found it's been a really
good way to
kind of share i guess share my view of
how
how these query engines get built or how
they're designed and
by people reading this it makes it
easier for them to contribute to the
project as well so
so yeah so if you're interested check
that out it's on leanpub
and yeah that's it thanks for listening
with some links there
i'm assuming i'll be able to share the
slides afterwards so
thank you
great thank you very much for the talk
um big round of virtual applause from
everybody i guess i'll be the only one
on microphone and video but
thank you very much for that talk uh so
we have a handful of questions
i am going to uh go through them this
one's not a question but it's a comment
that it's a great book and helps someone
with no experience with query engines
understand how they work
so hey kudos too great compliment on
there right
thank you yep yep said that good thank
you ken for that nice compliment
then um this seems to be a question
about code
um what is dot await it was um after
collect
yes okay so um rust rust uh
has some great async support so you can
have
uh you can have you can call it a method
and have it return a future
and dot away basically makes your code
wait for that eventual future to happen
and then it will carry on processing
um but the whole the whole point of this
trust async kind of ecosystem is that
you're not your code isn't like blocking
a thread waiting for the results
um that thread goes off to process other
code that's ready to run
and when you when your future is ready
your your code will get woken up again
and it's really a fantastic thing about
rust and the tokyo runtime
it it makes it very um it feels really
odd saying it's about rust and features
but it
actually makes it very easy to build
very scalable code
without being an expert in async in a
way
great yeah async is difficult yes
there is some async and r that some of
us are getting used to but it's you know
it's
hard um another question this is sort of
being asked
before you came on neil was able to
answer some of the questions but
can the rust client read and write
nested columns in arrow
um so yeah i'm gonna just
so arrow can the rust arrow client can
deal with nested types there are
there are some limitations i know um
one of the committees is working or is
working on some
improving the parquet support for
writing nested types but the arrow
library itself does support nested types
data fusion does not yet
um so for data fusion support nested
type somebody is going to have to go in
and do some work like on the sql planner
to understand
uh like compounds object names and map
flows to the
we need like a new contract in the
logical plans no it's not there it'd be
relatively easy
to implement that if somebody was um if
that was an important feature for
somebody
okay um that same person asked the
question
how can people contribute fantastic
questions so
um i would definitely encourage people
to go to the apache arrow
website and join the apache arrow
mailing list that would be a really kind
of great place to start
um so to give an idea so like but lister
is actually a tiny code base right now i
think it's where
uh 7000 lines of code but it's
leveraging all of this great stuff in
arrow and data fusion
um and there's plenty of work to do
there um so it'd be great there's uh we
use jira
to track all the issues um but the best
thing is join the mailing list say hello
um yeah ask ask you know where is help
needed
i myself have contributed um issues to
that jira tracker
fantastic i discovered a bug and
immediately prompted neil
to go take a look at it and they fixed
it really fast
it was impressive how fast within a day
uh so good good for them
um another question here is
um where did this go all right
are you working on all those pro on this
project as part of your nvidia job or
just for fun in your personal time
this is just for fun my personal time
right now so what are you working on in
nvidia
i'll follow up with that question sure
so i can't get into too much detail of
that probably but just a very high level
so we
i work on the rapids accelerator for
apache spark
it's basically an apache spark plug-in
that makes spark run on the gpu
so it translates spark query plans into
qdf query plans
and makes stuff run faster and so that's
that's like a really cool thing i mean
it's no coincidence that i'm doing
similar things in my day job and in my
spare time
it's through my spare time work that i
kind of got to in video i guess
um and i'm excited about adding the gpu
sport to ballista because i kind of know
how to do it from the day job so it's
kind of a natural
you know it's kind of a natural thing to
do here as well
um i have this kind of possibly naive
um hope that i can add gpu sports for
this to
the thing becomes really popular and it
becomes interesting between video but
that's just my
you know naive hope who knows that would
be nice you know i've been uh
i i told andy this but foreign a long
time to have
uh gpu data frames or r so hopefully i'm
hoping that this is the thing that
makes it happen um and speaking there's
a question here this is
the question that says what are the
target dates for 0.5 and 1.0
there are no target dates because it's a
spare time project it's my answer
one thing i've learned so this journey
this is like been three years
is to get to the point where register
actually works um so i'm incredibly
happy like over the past couple of weeks
it's got to this point
um but like other than you have to pace
yourself
um you can't treat your spare time
project as a job because you just get so
frustrated
so you know i get excited about a
feature i go and try and implement it
like some weekend it doesn't work out i
get frustrated i walk away for a bit
i come back when i feel like it and you
know it gets delivered when it gets
delivered and there are other people
doing the same so sorry no dates
all right that's fair and then given are
you even able to get your hands on a gpu
to test this because it seems like no
one can get a gpu these days
this is one advantage of working at
nvidia i was able to get myself an rtx
3080 from the employee store
that's how i got mine also um i was in
the i was at the headquarters and they
they walked me past the gift shop
and this back when they had a 1080 ti
and i i saw it sitting on the shelf i'm
like
i'm going to go to 1080 ti i just bought
it when i was on the tour very cool
yeah it's given being given tour by some
of the employees uh someone said no 30
90.
there were 30 90 spam chips okay fair
that's fair
all right um then we have a question
um any plan to support more
any plan to support more operators
additional to the relational operator
for instance this archive paper which i
can't that doesn't help you
it summarizes the data frame algebra i
guess
are you at i'm not quite maybe you know
what more that's what's yeah i mean i
would give the very kind of
um vague answers sure um i mean so
i guess my view on it so like so c core
and data for basics i mean sql is really
the starting point
um but people need to run the custom
codes so the next step
in my mind is like supporting udfs
column the udfs
it's user defined functions um but then
after that you want to have more
flexibility so you want to be able to
run operations that run on
entire partitions or entire batches so
yes you need all of those kind of
extension points for running your own
code and at that point
um so that's kind of an important point
when you're building a project like this
i think it's
important just to figure out these
extension points because once you have
the extension points in there then other
people can go and do
crazy things and do what they need to do
and
it makes it easier to put in new
features like that
okay and then i'll file that one up with
the udfs
is that just let's say we wrote a custom
r function which did an arbitrary code
i call from the r side that somehow that
gets planned and executed
by whatever engine's running it exactly
yeah so so kind of
looking through how that would work when
the ballista scheduler gets the query
it recognizes it's referring to some r
function um
so when it sends the query plan to the
executives it will have that information
the execution
would need some way to invoke that our
function i don't know how that would
work
whether it would be through some kind of
ffi call foreign function interface
whether it would have to
you know talk to another process through
shared memory or whatever
um but yeah the executive needs to know
how to invoke that code locally
so if it's an r function there might
need r in the executor if it's a python
function they need to be python in the
executor yeah exactly so like if you're
running kubernetes maybe you've got your
district executor and some r process
running in the same pod
um they can communicate with you with
each other somehow whether it's through
shared memory or networking
um or directly calling a lib cool
and then that actually is a nice segue
and about shared memory
uh does the data need to be written to
disk to be sent to executors executors
or can it be done through shared memory
except
they're writing to earlier and yes i
mean today
and again this is like extremely early
um but today
so yeah today the the initial data has
to be on disk
um it only supports reading from like
parking and csv so
it starts from disk it applies all the
operations the data is currently
persisted back to disk between each
query stage
um there is an issue open for adding
support for just keeping in memory
because if you have
you know maybe you do have kind of
smaller data you just want speed that's
just you know that's a good optimization
um so yeah i'm not sure if really
answered the question but right now it
has to start on disk and it is persisted
between stages
okay alexander there is an i o you're
going to hit when
you have to write to disk um
the question about for distributed teams
is schema registries
a best practice and could you guys to
explain more about schema registries
sure so the scheduler right now can use
xcd as a backing store
um for things like the cluster state and
queries that are currently being
processed and i think we probably
extend that to storing metadata about
schemas
so i mentioned with sql you know in sql
statements you you want to reference
tables by name
so you need you do need this kind of
registry that maps table names to some
schema and the firewall locations in the
cluster
um so yes you need to have that kind of
registry and and
right now the fcd is kind of where we're
going to be storing that so you can have
multiple schedulers running
and they all have access to the same
shared state
okay um
how does the flight ensure results are
in the correct order without a spark
driver
it's that's a great question so in
general it doesn't
it's so yeah if you're running a query
that finishes with an order by and you
want your client to receive
all the data um actually there's uh have
a discussion
i forget if it's in appear in a github
issue or not
um but the data from each executor would
be in order so you'd be doing the sorts
on each executor
and then you would need to you would
need to use a sort merge join algorithm
so from the client you can stream all
the data in parallel across the
executives you know each stream is
ordered
so basically the sort merged algorithm
you just read like you look at the first
item
in each stream compare them take the
lowest one
repeat until you've read all the data
okay
um any like scientific algorithms that
could be distributed like a distributed
xg boost a distributed linear regression
even or distributed distance matrix
so this is where i uh i don't have
experience in that area so i i cannot
answer that one my background is very
much more the kind of
traditional etl sequel kind of thing
okay so now a lot of those things are
distributed to bull
because you're just somehow getting the
framework to do it which
that's beyond me i'm sure it's possible
whether it's efficient or not i have no
idea
fair that's another question yeah um i
do remember i went to a talk a few years
ago
someone from lazada was saying eugene
tran member's last name now saying that
they have the largest state in the world
but they use spark to get it ready
by time they're ready to fit an xg boost
it fits on a single machine
and you don't need to shoot anymore but
some people like xgboost does distribute
it across gpus for a reason
um here's one one advantage of spark is
that it can pack uds for their
dependencies into a single jar
and distribute executors how will police
to support uds of arbitrary dependencies
you sort of
touched upon it so i guess yeah so so i
i have kind of mixed fews and acts i
have experience from previous jobs of
managing
kind of spot clusters where they're all
these jars flying rooms and no version
control and it can
it's really great when you're doing kind
of advanced stuff you're testing but it
can also be a nightmare in production
um so there are i guess yeah there are
kind of two
two things i see happening two different
features which will come at different
times
uh what i would like to do first is have
a way of packaging
packaging the dependencies in docker
images um so when you do for your
executors you have your own docker image
you extend the executive docker image
you put your you know all your
dependencies in there so when the
executive's running
it has a means to invoke your code um
but but i think it is really important
also to have the ability to
just have code on your clients and have
that magically streamed into the cluster
so you've got your lambda expressions
in whatever language um so i think we do
need to support that as well
i i know rust lambdas can be serialized
i don't have experience much with like
python and r and how that would really
work
i i know how it works in java so
yeah technically we can support those
things um
yeah and i imagine we would have to do
all of that at some point
all right thank you um oh someone asked
what
how about wasm for packaging right it
wasn't web assembly i'm really excited
about that but unfortunately i know
nothing about it really other than a few
blog posts i've read
there are some other people involved in
the project who are excited about it
um i'm pretty sure we will do something
with it but it's like very
i think a little bit too early to have
specific
um you know any kind of concrete answer
about where we're going to go with that
right so a pull request you'll take that
yeah if somebody has ideas yeah please
come along yep that's you hear it folks
give the ideas
all right i'll give everyone a last
chance to get squeezed one more question
in under the wire
so we will sit here and look at each
other awkwardly through the camera
waiting for a few moments just give
everyone a chance um and i will take
this time i want to
thank andy he did allude to it that i
asked him to speak of just a few weeks
ago
and he had to not only write a whole
talk but i actually make you know uh
get a whole new release for this talk so
let's give him a round of applause and a
spare time doing both of those things
it's been an exciting couple of weeks
yes yes it's been cool seeing that
um one of them says systems work
a wonderful systems work they say all
right so it looks like i'm just going to
install for another like
10 seconds and see if i see anyone's
typing
i don't think they do so i think we got
a lot of good questions in there
so i'll just do a few reminders before
we sign off
remember folks videos are up conference
videos at our stats.ai
meetup videos at myhackgar.org if you
want to help us make it look better
it's a github repo send us a pull
request we would love to get that
uh next three months are uh
going to be eric uh garrick adam blue
boo hi love sorry i have a little
toddler coming in here you can come here
okay all right we're gonna see uh
toddler as i give enough
finishing announcements here he's ready
for bed and should be in bed but he's
not
so he'll get to learn a little bit about
stats this way say hi
hi so march is going to be about
sharingan
april's going to be about russ congrats
from r may will be about
light gbm in our and
someone wants to order andy if for andy
a talk for the pizza for the talk
so whoever wants to give andy a pizza uh
find him on twitter and dm him or
something
yes i'm sorry let's give daddy one
second all right thank you very much
everybody
have a great time and very much thank
you andy for you this wonderful talk
i had a great time hope everyone else
did too and virtual applause for you
thank you very much
thanks for tuning thank you thank you
have a good night everybody